representative Bernie Sanders thank you
Miss leader I've introduced legislation
in the last three sessions of Congress
that would raise the minimum wage to
five dollars and fifty cents an hour and
I think senator Daschle said it well
this is a modest proposal if you end up
making five dollars and fifteen cents an
hour you are not doing very very well
many of us would go further but I think
we're all excited that the president
leadership is on support to raise the
minimum wage so that people can at least
escape the abyss of poverty in the
recent election sixty-two percent of the
american people including many many
low-income workers did not vote and in
my view the reason they did not vote is
they're seeing their jobs go to third
world countries they are working and
slaving away at four and a quarter or
four fifty an hour and they look to
washington and they saying what are you
guys doing do you know that we are alive
do you know that we're in pain well
today at least some of us are saying we
hear you we know you can't survive on
florida quarter an hour we're disgraced
at the gap between the rich and the poor
is growing wider we want you to
participate in politics we want you and
your kids to earn a decent living we
hear you we're going to fight for your
rights last point that i would like to
make we hear a whole lot about welfare
reform in this institution I get very
upset when you have workers who are
making Florida quarter an hour who then
have to go out and get food stamps paid
for by taxpayers have to go out and get
medicaid paid for by taxpayers live and
subsidized housing paid for by taxpayers
in other words the American middle class
is subsidizing employers who are not
paying their workers a living wage it
seems to me in this country people who
work for a living have the right to work
for at least minimum wages that provide
them with sustenance sustems and people
who employ workers do not have should
not have to go to the government for
corporate welfare in order to subsidize
those wages I hope very much and I'm
sure that the president and the
leadership will take this fight to the
heartland of America the people are
waiting to hear the United States
Congress stand up and fight for their
rights and I think we're off to a good
start